this video is made possible by Backblaze
the unlimited backup solution you can
get a 15-day free trial at Backblaze
calm /bi graphics Heinrich Miller was
the man who ran the most feared of all
institutions in Nazi Germany the Gestapo
never a devout Nazi he brought an
unquestioning adherence to orders and a
cold calculating efficiency to create an
atmosphere of terror suspicion and
darkness and then with the Nazi regime
crumbling around him he simply
disappeared or did he
in this week's by graphics we take a
look at the life and the disappearance
of Heinrich Muller
[Music]
hinrich mallet was born to Catholic
parents in Munich Germany on April the
28th 1900 he had a middle-class
upbringing with his father serving as a
rural police officer Heydrich
experienced a primary school level
education before going on to train as an
apprentice mechanic in the exciting new
field of aircraft engineering
seventeen-year-old mala joined the
German army in June 1917 and in the 17
months that were to remain of the first
world war 1 both promotion and acclaim
in April 1918 he was assigned to the
flagger hours building up halong 287
where he flew planes in an artillery
spotting unit in August 1918 Mulla was
promoted to NCO he was awarded the Iron
Cross first and second class while
serving on the Western Front after
sustaining a leg injury in a plane
accident he was awarded the retired
Bavarians badge his medal Hall during
his short period of service also
included the Bavarian Military Cross
second class with swords it was quite an
accomplishment for an eighteen-year-old
[Music]
after leaving the German army mala
founds employment as a junior assistant
for the Munich police force after a
period of time he passed his entrance
exam to become a police officer by now
he had reached his full height of five
foot seven inches tall and he had a
strong athletic built
Mulla kept his dark brown hair cropped
very short on the sides
he had a small mouth and was rarely seen
to smile while his extremely intense
stare would often unnerve those in his
company the First World War injury that
had ended his war career caused him to
walk with a constant limp will a married
a girl named Sophie Dischler in 1924
Sophie's father was the publisher of a
right-wing newspaper Rome was opposed to
the new National Socialist Party and its
leader Adolf Hitler mullah was to stick
to his faith throughout his career
despite the Nazi party's antipathy
towards the church three years into the
marriage a son Reinhard was born the
marriage was to last for some thirteen
years with a second child a girl named
Elizabeth born on September the 9th 1936
the child was said to be not quite right
which led to a strain in the marriage
subsequently engaged in an affair with
his private secretary Barbara Hellmuth
and the marriage it was essentially over
over a ten year period Miller rose in
the ranks to become police secretary in
1929 by now he was serving in the
section 6 of the Bavarian State Police
this unit was mainly concerned with
seeking out and keeping a lid on
communist activity in and around Munich
by the time he had reached the age of 30
Muller had become a rabid and D
communist thanks in part to his having
been a witness to communist hostage
murders during the Bavarian State
Republic during the German revolution of
1918 to 1919 his energetic performance
of his duties and willingness to follow
orders without question earmarked him as
a man with a future in the new Germany
during his service with the Bavarian
State Police Muller ran in circles that
included Nazi leaders Reinhard Heydrich
and Heinrich Himmler however at this
time Muller no doubt under the influence
of his father-in-law was decidedly
anti-nazi when the Nazis overthrew the
Bavarian government on March the 9th
1933 Mulla was in favour of picking up
arms to actively resist Hitler's forces
[Music]
with the very air in its police force
under the control of the Nazis mullah
proved to be a valuable asset for the
new regime his knowledge of communist
activities put him in high demand and he
advanced in rank to become a criminal
investigator in November of 1933 he was
a bit of a workaholic who exhibited a
high degree of self-discipline and
ruthlessness his early experiences in
the Army had instilled in him a military
compliance to orders that was highly
appreciated by his Nazi leaders his
natural antipathy towards the Nazi Party
kept him alert from becoming a member
until he was compelled to do so in 1939
he had earlier referred to Hitler as an
immigrant unemployed house painter as a
result of his anti-nazi sentiments he
was kept under constant surveillance by
the party a 1937 report referred to him
as ruthless and continually tries to
demonstrate his efficiency but claims
all the glory for himself however the
chief of the Reich main security office
Reinhard Heydrich saw a lack of blind
devotion to the Nazi Party there's an
asset he was increasingly impressed by
Muller having kept a close eye on his
police career in Mullah he saw a man who
was completely focused on the minut
detail of his job description without a
concern for the bigger picture from 1933
onward Muller began doing work for the
Nazi Party under the direction of
Heydrich he would be given accounts and
reports detailing Nazi atrocities and
turned them in to dry administrative
reports in 1934 he joined the Secret
Service for the SS in 1933 when Adolf
Hitler became Chancellor of Germany
Hermann Goering Hitler's
second-in-command became interior
minister of Prussia this put him in
command of the largest police force in
Germany Goering created the Gestapo by
amalgamating the various branches of the
Prussian police forces the name was an
abbreviation of ghee Heiner starts
policia or secret police on April the
20th 1934 SS leader Heinrich Himmler
became the head of the Gestapo on that
same day Hitler appointed Himmler chief
of police for all states apart from
Prussia two days later
Himmler handed the leadership of the
Gestapo to Reinhard Heydrich who still
retained his position
head of the SS on June the 17th 1936
Hitler appointed Himmler as chief of all
German police including those in Prussia
this move gave him la operational
control over all of Germany's detective
forces the Gestapo had now become a
national agency as opposed to simply a
Prussian state agency Ellison created
the criminal policia or Criminal Police
merging it with the Gestapo to form the
cipo or secret police Heydrich retains
control making Heinrich Muller and his
operational chief in the wake of
Hitler's 1938 arms loss of Austria
Muller was also made inspector of
security police for Austria it was
Muller who gave the orders that resulted
in the arrest of up to 30,000 Jews on
the night of November the 9th to the
10th 1938 a date that history remembers
as the crystal nacht or the night of
broken glass as a subordinate of
Heydrich he also did most of the
administrative work in preparing for the
emigration of all Jews from Europe under
the auspices of the central office for
Jewish emigration three years later on
September the 27th 1939 the security and
police agencies all over the country
were brought together to form the right
name security office or our MSA which
was under the control of Heydrich the
Gestapo was now officially Department
four of the our NSA Heinrich Amala he
was named the Gestapo chief
will her finally joined the Nazi Party
in November of 1939 after being
pressured to do so by Heydrich from this
time onward he became known as Gestapo
Muller to differentiate him from another
Nazi official who bore the same name
[Music]
on August the 11th 1939 Adolf Hitler
stated the following to the League of
Nations High Commissioner if there is
the slightest provocation I will shatter
Poland without warning into so many
pieces that there will be nothing left
to pick up what he needed next was that
provocation which would allow him to
unleash his war machine and set the
world on the road to war to create it he
turned to the Gestapo
as a result Heydrich and Merlo worked
together to bring about the Polish
provocation that Hitler had warned about
the plot to create the ruse of a Polish
propagation was called Operation
Tannenberg they decided to create a
series of fake border attacks in which
Germans living on the Polish border
would be the victims of attacks by
Polish insurgents Miller and Heydrich
settled on the border area near the town
of Grievous
here were situated isolated German
outposts that would make logical targets
for attack it was decided that fake
attacks would be made on a forestry
station a Customs House and a radio
station SS soldiers were recruited into
the scheme and dressed as Polish
insurgents and as Polish army personnel
more SS troops were then clad in German
army uniforms a last-minute touch to the
plan was that some of the poles would be
killed in the attack so that their
bodies could be presented to the world's
media concentration camp inmates were
brought in to play the part of these
poles who were about to be put to death
operation Tannenberg was stationed to go
into action of 4:30 a.m. on August the
26th there were to be three successive
code words and the various units were to
cross the border once the last codeword
was issued but after the release of the
second codeword some units became
confused and headed for the border
prematurely but then Hitler changed his
mind the attack would be delayed men on
motorbikes were sent out to bring back
the attacking fake poles Hillard held
back because of British guarantees to
Poland after consultation with Heydrich
and Muller it was decided that the plan
would be revised it was also felt that a
real Polish insurgent would be needed so
that he could be put to death and
paraded to the world's newspapers Muller
searched through his files and came up
with the name of Franz Hahn iakh who was
a prominent Polish sympathizer on August
the 30th
send his men to pick up honey oak the
attacks were carried out on the evening
of August the 31st starting at 8:00 p.m.
a drugged Franz Hani oak was dragged out
and propped up against the radio station
entrance
he was then shot in the head photos were
taken and delivered back to mother and
Heydrich but they were deemed as not
being good enough to be used for media
propaganda purposes
still the fake attacks served their
purpose the following day September the
1st 1939 Adolf Hitler referred to them
as justification for his attack on
Poland
two days later Britain and France
declared war on Germany and the Second
World War was underway
[Music]
Heinrich Muller was now in charge of the
most ruthless arm of the Nazi Party his
brief was to stamp out all manner of
oppression to the regime he immediately
set about in his methodically efficient
manner to create an instrument of
state-sponsored terror the Gestapo were
given the job of investigating every act
of treason espionage and sabotage
perpetrated against the state a law that
had been passed in 1936 gave them free
rein to operate without any restraint
this law gave the organization exemption
from any responsibility to the
Administrative course so long as the
Gestapo were acting in harmony with the
will of the Nazi leadership than they
were acting lawfully the aspect of the
Gustavo's activities that was most open
to abuse was called the shuts aft which
translates to protective custody it gave
them the authority to imprison anyone
without having gone through any court
proceedings as a result thousands of
people were beaten mercilessly with many
of them simply disappearing
this gave the Gestapo a fearsome
reputation throughout the land fear
in fact became the Gustavo's greatest
weapon Muller was a highly skilled
interrogator himself he would draw
interrogations out for hours on end
making full use of his incredible memory
to trip up his subjects we only have one
surviving account of an interrogation
conducted by Muller his opening words to
his subject a British officer were you
are in the hands of the Gestapo don't
imagine that we shall show you the
slightest consideration with the onset
of war the Gestapo numbers were
bolstered substantially by 1942 Muller
was in charge of around 46,000 officers
as German conquests mounted the
operations of the Gestapo were extended
to occupied territories its duties were
extended to putting down resistance
movements to do this effectively with
only 46,000 men will have cultivated the
perception among the population that the
state was constantly watching and that
nobody was safe the mere sight of a
Gestapo unit would instill terror in
people the general feeling was that if
you did anything against the Nazi stage
the Gestapo would eventually track you
down and then your life simply wouldn't
be worth living in order to cultivate
the fear that was needed to control the
people
was happy to leak the details of the
sorts of torture that his underlings
were inflicting upon those taken into
custody the more gruesome the story the
better he also organized for occasional
show trials to be held in public where
the People's Court would vehemently
denounced convict and then condemn a
prisoner to the firing squad mullahs
favorite People's Court judge was the
notorious Roland Frei slur the Castillo
had officers at every concentration camp
the Snell from the Gestapo were also
used to make up the Einsatzgruppen or
death squads who carried out mass
killings
the Gestapo were largely responsible for
putting into action Hitler's plan for
the elimination of the Jewish people
from Europe to accomplish this the
office of resettlement later to become
the office of Jewish Affairs was created
it was headed by Adolf Eichmann who was
Miller's immediate subordinate together
the two men implemented mass deportation
and extermination zat Nazi concentration
camps throughout occupied Europe on
March the 2nd 1944 Muller signs the
infamous bullet decree which ordered
that escaped allied prisoners were to be
transported to the mouth house and
Goosen concentration camp and summarily
executed this was in direct
contravention of the Geneva Convention
in the wake of the July the 20th 1944
plot to kill Hitler
it was Miller who authorized the use of
torture to interrogate those involved in
fact his zeal in the aftermath of the
attack and him the Knights cross to the
war service with swords under his
oversight more than 7,000 people were
arrested with 4980 either committing
suicide or being executed Bullis duties
included overseeing counter espionage
operations between 1942 and 1945 these
were focused on the Soviet Union
much success was achieved in feeding
false information to the Russians and
even in turning a number of Soviet
agents
[Music]
Mulla may have never been a
dyed-in-the-wool nazi but he believed
that German victory was inevitable even
in the last days he thought that a final
German victory in the our den could turn
the tide of the war as the Russians and
the Americans closed in on Berlin in
April of 1945 Muller was among those
secrets in the underground bunker that
was now home to the Fuhrer in the final
days Hitler discovered that Hermann
Goering had secretly undertaken peace
negotiation with the Allies enraged the
Fuhrer ordered Muller to interrogate
waffen-ss general hermann fegelein about
what he knew of Goering --zz underhanded
dealings this interrogation his last
official duty resulted in the execution
of fegelein on April 30th Adil Hitler
and his wife Eva Braun committed suicide
the next day May the first mullah was
quoted by hitler's personal pilot as
saying we know the russian methods
exactly i haven't the faintest intention
of being taken prisoner by the russians
that evening Miller disappeared from the
bunker what happened to him remains one
of the great mysteries of the Nazi era
for almost 70 years he remains the most
senior Nazi official to remain
unaccounted for
On June the 18th 1945 the Allied
counterintelligence war room released a
statement that concluded that it seems
clear from most reports that Muller
remained in Berlin after the collapse
over the next few weeks several
high-ranking Gestapo officers were
arrested but the man at the head of the
terror organization was nowhere to be
found with Heinrich Muller being a
common german name the Allies found many
Mueller's but never the right one this
led to many false alerts and frustrating
dead ends still the United States
counterintelligence services were
determined to track him down there were
reports that he had taken on the name of
Schwarz or schwarzer and travelled south
in the company of a fellow Gestapo
officer but this ended up as yet another
dead end
by the mid 1940s the general consensus
was that Heinrich Muller had died
[Music]
the dramatic May 1960 capture of Adolf
Eichmann by the Israelis reawakened
interest in the search for escaped Nazis
in general and Heinrich Miller in
particular Eichmann himself added to the
interest by stating at his trial that he
was of the opinion that Muller was still
alive in July 1960 the West German
police were bordered to open an
investigation into Mueller's whereabouts
it was suspected that wherever he was
Muller was corresponding with his family
former secretary or mistress all of
these people were therefore put under
surveillance the West Germans developed
three major leads in the case each one
confirming their belief that he had met
his end in Berlin in 1945 this
eventually led to the excavation of a
grave in a cemetery in West Berlin
despite the fact that the gravestone
tread our loving father Heinrich Muller
born April the twenty eighth nineteen
hundred thousand Berlin May 1945 the
grave did not contain mullahs body the
American CIA began to search for Muller
at around the same time as this West
German investigation it was prompted by
the defection of a Polish intelligence
officer who revealed information about a
handful of escaped Nazis including
Muller the defector informed the CIA
that Muller had been taken into custody
by the Soviets and was working in Moscow
in counterintelligence
the CIA attempted to corroborate the
Polish defectors information with
limited success throughout the remainder
of the 1960's there were various reports
of mullah living in South American
countries such as Argentina or Chile
still no concrete leads emerged though
finally in 2013
it appeared that conclusive evidence had
emerged proving that Heinrich Muller did
in fact die in Berlin in 1945 research
on the part of the memorial for German
resistance concluded that he was buried
in a mass grave with around 2400 other
people in Berlin the conclusion is based
on a report of a burial commander which
detailed the discovery of the body
complete with Mona's military
identification papers in his pocket so
it would appear that the most elusive of
the Nazi hierarchy is not similar loose
avowal just before we finished the video
today I do want to say a particularly
big thank you to today's sponsor
Backblaze now videos like this I
personally feel they're important but
because of the way YouTube works it's
hard for them to be made because of
advertising restrictions on YouTube that
you're probably familiar with if you're
a regular watcher of well anything on
YouTube
now this sponsor they also happen to
provide an amazing service so please do
support them and support us by checking
out this great deal Backblaze they're a
backup solution and it really is simply
the best way to backup any files that
you have on your computer as a Video
Creator I work with a lot of data and I
need that all to be securely backed up
which I do with back laser in fact as I
sit here my computer is over there
syncing my files with back blazars
servers securely of course they use
military-grade encryption now I've used
Backblaze for years they provide
unlimited personal storage for a low
monthly theme and better yet it's
totally hands-off when I put a file on
my computer or save a new document or do
anything like that that place
automatically gets to work mirroring
that file that video with their service
then if I ever have a computer failure
on my data gets destroyed somehow
touchwood I can just download it from
back place or more likely just let them
ship me out a hard disk for a refundable
fee with all my files on it but if
you're not sure this is for you then you
can find out if it's for you with the
15-day free trial that our users get
just for watching via graphics you can
find a link to that in the description
below
like I say sponsors on this type of
video it's super important and I'd love
it if you tried the mouse just go to bag
Blais comm /bi our graphics again as I
said there's a link in the description
below give this video a like if you
liked it subscribe for more stuff twice
a week and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]